je vous dis c'est encore plus sûr que de
l'aspirine qu'en pensez-vous docteur
incroyable il est hors de question
d'abandonner ta vie par envriie il est
hors de question d'abandonner mes rêves
pourter un médicament révolutionnaire je
promets de donner un sens à ma vie c'est
pas 100 cas que tu vas te faire cette
année ce sera plutôt dans les
600 je promets de donner un sens à ma
vie sens s je promets de donner un sens
à ma vie sens sens je promets de donner
un sens à ma viille
s je ve un verre ouais on prendra ce que
vous buvez non non vous ne méritez pas
ce que je bois quand ma femme était
mourante sa maladie m'a offert une
espèce de feu créatif transforme ton
malheur en un feu créatif vous savez
combien ça coûte de lustrer ce sol e oui
80000 dollars le malheur to j'ai bien
envie de t'en coller une le fa nos
ventes sont au point morts le malheur
pourquoi pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toute souffrance sou pas dans la finance
souff représentant
pharmaceutique
souff la logique des big PHA c'est
s'approcher au plus près de la limite
sans jamais la franchir vous vendez ce
que vous avez en magasin c'est les
commissions qui vontvoyer au paradis il
faut avoir les couilles de se baisser de
les gratter
t
ta S et moi allons casser la baraque
avec nos projets vous allez faire des
webcam ou alors ah oui je sais du vol
d'identitéckie Dr de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chez c'est déueul oh vous avez vendu du
fin d'année comme si j'étais le ch
trafiant